il ya route ce matin consacre un article
à la reconnaissance faciale ce
dispositif technologique qui permet en
branchant des caméras sur des fichiers
de police d'identifier les gens qui se
promènent dans la rue ça a déjà été
testé dans un certain nombre d'endroits
en france notamment par la ville de nice
lors du dernier carnaval de la ville
les 19 et 20 février derniers l'avantagé
la reconnaissance faciale c'est que ça
permet de retrouver des enfants perdus
ou d'arrêter des personnes dangereuses
et recherchées
ça permet aussi de ficher les gens par
exemple en chine quand vous traversez la
rue à un endroit qui n'est pas autorisé
vous êtes aussitôt identifié
on peut projeter votre visage sur des
espèces de deux tableaux d'infamie pour
que vos concitoyens savent que vous avez
enfreint la loi
on peut aussi vous envoyer directement
des amendes voire dégradé votre note
sociale et du coup vous empêcher de
pouvoir par exemple mettre vos enfants
dans certaines écoles ou d'avoir accès à
un crédit
nicolas bouzou l'objet de votre dernier
livre sagesse et folie du monde qui
vient c'est de dire ne soyons pas trop
pessimistes notamment vis-à-vis de la
technologie est ce que vous vous avez 7
ce parti-pris d'optimisme y compris avec
des technologies comme l'a reconnu ce
mail facile tout dépend comment les
utiliser tout dépend comment l'état de
droit garanti nos libertés au fond en
tant qu'européens en tant que français
le développement de la reconnaissance
faciale ne me fait pas du tout peur
parce que bien des réglementations il ya
de la régulation et je n'ai pas deux
pareils je ne nourris pas de paranoïa
excessif quand à l'utilisation que l'on
pourrait faire deux mondes de mon visage
si j'étais citoyens chinois mais où même
quand je me rends nous nous rendons en
chine évidemment je suis très mal à
l'aise avec ça parce que je sais bien
que ce n'est pas un état de droit qui
protège l'utilisation qui sera faite de
mon de mon visage dont derrière ça la
question est moins celle de la
technologie que celle de la régulation
il faut faire très attention à ça parce
que la puissance technologique dans les
mains d'une dictature ça devient quelque
chose d'abominable est extrêmement
dangereux mais dans le cadre d'une
démocratie libérale avec un état de
droit c'est quelque chose d'absolument
formidable parce que vous n'avez très
bien dit la reconnaissance faciale
elle est faite pour poursuivre des gens
qui ont volé des vélos cambriolé des des
appartements que sais-je et de ce point
de vue là comme la vidéosurveillance
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue là c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
extrêmement positif en tout cas ce que
je sais c'est qu'il est formidable que
des grands médias s'en emparent et il
faut que le débat intellectuel que
débats politiques s'emparent de ces
sujets ce qu'on appelle plus globalement
les technologies de la troisième
révolution industrielle à part le fait
que cela vous inquiète
ce qui m'inquiète effectivement d'abord
c'est l'usager qui sont que ceux qui
sont faites de ces données notamment par
exemple en australie il y avait eu des
tentatives de l'usaj de l'intelligence
artificielle et de la reconnaissance
faciale puisque c'est extrêmement liés
notamment dans le cadre scolaire et puis
finalement ils en sont revenus parce que
les parents d'élèves eux mêmes ils
étaient opposés les enseignants aussi
moi je pense que la civilisation des
machines n'a pas d'identité culturelle
n'a pas d'identité nationale que
justement ce sont des phénomènes qui ne
faut pas regarder justement avec un
regard ou français ou chinois il faut
vraiment avoir conscience que c'est
quelque chose de planétaire et que cette
civilisation là elle met en danger
l'humanité tout entière
et de ce point de vue je pense qu'il
faut être extrêmement vigilant à un
encadrement très strict de ces de ce
système mais je ne suis pas naïve et je
sais très bien que la civilisation des
machines telles qu'elle a commencé déjà
sa course folle à la fin du 19e siècle
pour montrer l'ampleur du délire dans
lequel elle est en train de nous plonger
et de le métamorphoser profondément les
êtres humains peut nous conduire au
désastre et je pense même en ce qui me
concerne à la destruction de l'humanité
mais si c'est ce que souhaite après tout
la planète et en particulier de
continuer à faire la politique de
l'autruche en pensant que les chinois le
fond mais c'est pas bien parce qu'ils le
font mal mais nous heureusement on est
dans notre petite bulle des démocrates
je pense qu'on se leurre largement non
je suis encore plus en désaccord avec
vous que vous ne l'exprimé c'est dire
que je pense que oui je pense que pour
nous c'est absolument formidable on a
accès à la culture comme on n'a jamais
eu on a un accès la musique comme on en
a jamais eu
on a un accès à la mobilité comme on n'a
jamais eu on a un accès à la santé moi
je travaille beaucoup sur les questions
de santé
c'est technologie la apporte des
réponses à des gens qui n'avaient pas de
solution thérapeutique
il ya encore deux ou trois ans donc je
pense que l'intelligence
oui mais ça c'est l'argument en
particulier ça mérite d'être étudiée sur
la santé c'est toujours d'ailleurs
l'argument massue c'est de nous parler
des progrès dans la mx à l'espérance de
vie à 60 ans moi j'aime bien y allait
aussi de nouvelles maladies qui se
répondent et de suez et qui elles ne
connaissent toujours pas solutions et
notamment la résistance aux
antibiotiques nous prépare de joyeuses
heures et là dessus je crois que
là-dessus la stylisation des machines et
en espérance de vie est oui mais quand
on sera éradiquée liant recteur et multi
résiste mais savait nous apaiser en
pleine forme et sur son clavier pour
très longtemps figure fille même si je
vous dis mais garantit sa vie n'allait
pas mourir de sciences dans sa voiture
et que vous allez mourir très tard et
pas de ça est en tout cas je peux vous
dire que si on avait eu ce débat ya un
siècle de toute façon il y aurait
personne ici parce que l'espérance de
vie elle était de 29 ans je ne veux pas
faire de l'espace y est je ne suis pas
sûr qu'ils aient des personnes
oui à part vous pardon c'est à part vous
il n'ya personne de moins de 29 ans sur
ce plateau alain benedetti pense qu'il
faut retrouver une vision critique de la
technique je sais d'accord avec ce que
vous dites c'est que finalement il ya
quelque chose qui manque beaucoup
aujourd'hui pour comprendre et
vraisemblement apprivoiser et réguler la
technique c'est cette vision critique de
la technique c'est que l'irénisme qui
consiste à dire que la technique c'est
formidable à mon avis c'est un discours
qui ne suffit pas en soi et ce qui ne
suffit pas en soi c'est de croire que
parce que nous sommes dans des mots dans
des démocraties que le système
technicien n'est pas des structures moi
j'invite tout le monde à relire un
auteur qu'on ne l'est plus du tout
aujourd'hui mais qui était absolument
prophétique qui a dit des choses
extrêmement pertinente et intelligente
sur la question du système technicien
c'est jacques ellul jacques ellul 10 est
une chose très juste il disait le
système technicien devient autonome il
finit à un moment donné par échapper aux
hommes
et c'est bien là qu'est le problème et
il disait autre chose il disait vous
pouvez inventé tous les comités
d'éthique qui de la terre ce qui se fait
ce qui ce qui est prévu ce qui doit se
faire se fera et que les comités
d'éthique sont bien plus des jardin
d'acclimatation d'un certain nombre
disons de conséquences non maîtrisée du
progrès technologique que de véritable
mode de régulation
donc je suis d'accord avec vous bien
évidemment la technique c'est janus il y
à des apports incontestable ça nous
donne plus de mobilité
ça nous permet de mieux nous soigner ça
nous permet de mieux nous cultiver tout
ça est formidable mais derrière quand
même il faut toujours avoir en tête que
la technique c'est quelque chose qui
évolue de manière autonome et qu'il faut
une régulation très fortes et une
volonté politique très forte pour
maîtriser la technique et on voit bien
que quand même la question des libertés
publiques se pose parce que la question
de la reconnaissance faciale
je veux dire vas finir va poser des
problèmes dans nos sociétés y compris
dans nos sociétés démocratiques qui sont
largement régulé par l'état de droit ont
fait en tout cas qu'ils pensent l'être
les points de vue d'internautes avant de
continuer ce débat passionnant au nous
avons posé la question sur twitter avez
vous peur de la reconnaissance faciale
ben pas trop 59% des votants n'en a pas
peur on rappelle que c'est pas un
sondage vous donnez votre avis en direct
pendant l'émission vous livrer vos
témoignages aussi philo nous dit pas
peur du tout point d'exclamation je n'ai
rien à me reprocher et babine odyssée
comme article 3 de la loi anti-casseurs
vous savez celle qui a été censuré par
le conseil constitutionnel
le problème n'est pas l'outil mais
l'homme qui va s'en servir
emmanuelle barbara votre point de vue
oui enfin c'est une fin c'est une
question délicate parce qu'en gros c'est
liberté ou sécurité alors on peut pas
opter même si autour de la table
j'imagine que personne à se reprocher
grand chose enfin il faut le souhaiter
encore que si on regarde bien
si jamais la touche à un truc qui va
donc heureusement voilà mais ce point on
ne peut pas opter collectivement comme
un seul homme pour la sécurité c'est à
dire que les aspects que vous soulignez
qui correspondent à la façon lumineuse
de cette technologie
enfin lumineuse au sens de l'année le
progression pour l'écologie voilà le
problème c'est qu'on a un exemple in
concreto actuelle parfaitement et puis
rien qu'au début puisque les absorber le
surcroît 45% des moyens de
reconnaissance faciale pour le monde
entier qu'ils en sont au début
ils pensent ils pensent non pas mais ils
veulent investir davantage encore sa
promesse en millions de caméras
c'est absolument magnifique et 2
milliards d'image qui sont diplômés
matin midi et soir et ce faisant ils ont
déjà mis paraît-il dans certaines zones
de chine de l'ouest les les population
ouïghoure dont on mesure la
fréquentation des dés comment dirais-je
des rentes voilà donc très bien donc ça
c'est absolument absolument
insupportable absolument seul maintenant
ramener dans notre univers à nous c'est
vrai que c'est une question de droit que
la question des droits fondamentaux on
disait libertés publiques dans le temps
mais finalement maintenant dix droits
fondamentaux salaire de poser davantage
mais dans le fond mais dans le fond
c'est de ce long de ce nom en parler
c'est vrai qu'il ya une forme de
intéressante presque paradoxal de voir
le surgissement de cette technologie
celle ci et d'autres de surveillance
d'une manière ou d'une autre qui
pourrait servir à la surveillance et qui
viennent ne veut franchement interagir
ou atteindre notre vie privée et notre
notre vie privée c'est à dire notre
sphère dans laquelle nous avons droit et
s'est reconnue par par diverses chartes
et constitution et le droit le droit
européen de de nous mouvoir librement
donc cette question là et comment est-ce
qu'on est absolument essentiel à
résoudre pour pouvoir concilier dans le
fond la propagation positive de ce genre
de de ce genre de technologie mais dans
une sphère une sphère où l'on ne soit
pas où l'on ne soit pas contraint alors
à seysses à ce stade est à 7 minutes
nous avons la rgpp des donc le règlement
général de protection des données qui
permet s'agissant des données
biométriques de pouvoir exercer un droit
d'opposition c'est à dire de dire je ne
veux pas qu'on utilise mes données j'ai
l'impression enfin cet intéressant comme
comme mesure mais je ne sais pas à
l'aune d'une application j'allais dire
dans dans la sphère publique à
l'extérieur dans la rue à dans les
aéroports etc
comment exercer vraiment ce droit je
vois bien
en entreprise mais dans cette forme là
c'est un peu plus difficile à avoir mais
clairement à on aura probablement en
droit à une plus grande à une plus un
plus grand recours à ce genre de
technologie et 2 la réglementation sera
sera exigée y compris les microsoft et
amazon demande aux états de bien vouloir
prévoir des déréglementations qui
permettent de maintenir transparence
d'impartialité et c'est parce qu'en plus
il ya des billets en plus de tout le
reste
il ya des billets donc disons que on est
en cours enfin on tâtonne on avance
c'est là qu'on verra bien on se dit que
on est à peu près protéger parce que
dans nos démocraties c'est l'état qui a
cassé fichiers avec nos photos qu'on a
donné pour notre carte d'identité mais
facebook par exemple elle a les photos
de centaines de millions voire de
milliards de gens oui alors les gens
sont pas obligés de les donner non plus
réservé bon mais il se trouve que
facebook à 2,3 milliards d'utilisateurs
dans le monde sa filiale instagram donc
d'image de photos à de mémoire en 34 5
milliards d'utilisateurs dans le monde
ces gens-là dont je fais partie derrière
on les force pas à donner leur a donné
leur image si vous voulez on y trouve
forcément les jeunes adolescents qui
effectivement sont quand même un petit
peu crédule on les force pas donner
leurs impressions sociale exercée sur ne
me faites pas passer pour un naïf que je
ne suis en aucun cas ce que je veux dire
c'est que moi je suis très sensible à ce
que vous dire la critique vient dans des
guerres au fond la vraie critique
philosophique sur le monde de la
technique parce que énorme je vous dis
ça parce que dans le livre qu'on a sorti
avec luxury ont fait un sort à ellul
notamment sur les questions de fin du
travail de revenu universel qui nous
semble quelque chose d'absolument
dramatique des idées absolument
dramatique pour notre pour notre société
mais mais la question de la dépossession
par la technique
évidemment j'y suis extrêmement sensible
mais c'est pas en refusant à la
technique qu'on aura la moindre
influence et d'ailleurs je vais vous
provoquer un peu mais vous évoquez le
rgp des dons je sais bien tout le monde
en europe s'enorgueillit je veux dire
ceux qui sont les principaux
bénéficiaires de la du rgp des c'est pas
les consommateurs européens
ce sont les industriels chinois parce
que eux ils
pas le rg [ __ ] et avec ce type de
réglementation nous délocalisons nous
délocalisons notre industrie numérique
robotique intelligence artificielle aux
chinois et aux américains et on devrait
quand même réfléchir à ça notamment les
gens qui sont proches des idées
souverainistes au fond s'il ya un grand
remplacement aujourd'hui pour employer
une expression qui fait scandale
mais ce grand remplacement il est avant
tout technologique et économique
c'est le fait que dans cette technologie
là
l'europe est en situation de sous
traitance et ça ça m'inquiète beaucoup
je pense qu'on a répondu qu à philo qui
nous disait que penser du règlement
européen de 2016 sur la protection des
données
et bien voilà on vient d'en parler et
christian la génération facebook
trouvera ça normal
juste ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est qu'il faut bien distinguer la
technique de la connaissance et le
problème c'est que quand vous regardez
l'histoire des innovations et quand vous
regardez l'histoire de la science
notamment c'est que la technique très
souvent on va beaucoup plus vite que la
science c'est à dire que ont produit des
applications ont produit des innovations
sans véritablement comprendre qu'elles
sont finalement les conséquences que
pourraient avoir ces innovations sur les
comportements sur la santé sur tout un
ensemble de domaines dans lesquels avec
lesquels nous devons nous devons nous
devons compter donc c'est tout là c'est
toute la difficulté à laquelle sont
confrontées d'ailleurs aujourd'hui les
politiques est l'un des sujets auxquels
aussi sont confrontés les politiques
c'est que les questions technologiques
nos logiques les questions d'innovation
les questions mêmes scientifiques qui
n'étaient pas des questions politiques
ou en tout cas quitté des questions qui
n'étaient pas traités dans l'espace
public vont le devenir de plus en plus
et je crois véritablement que ce
phénomène de démocratisation des enjeux
technologiques des enjeux pour les
enjeux politiques de la technologie va
de plus en plus posée sur le débat sur
le débat public on le voit d'ailleurs
avec les questions sur les ogm et c'est
quelque chose d'assez positif de ce
point de vue là je terminerai sur
heidegger et sur jacques ellul je suis
désolé parce que je suis un fervent
défenseur d'un jules méline des manques
elle est l'auteure quel est l'auteur qui
n'a pas commis d'erreur je pense qu'il a
quand même commis moins d'erreurs dans
ses engagements politiques que martin
heidegger
merci on va passer à un autre sujet mais
qui là encore pose des problèmes
éthiques
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur avait réuni ses homologues
du g7
c'était vendredi dernier à paris et il a
fait cette déclaration qui n'est pas du
tout passé inaperçu pour lui certaines
ong sont coupables de collusion ou voire
de complicité avec les passeurs de
méditerranée en méditerranée sans